When I die, I want to
be stuffed and turned
into a robot on the Pirates
of the Caribbean ride.
You cannot actually do that.
But there are some
other awesome things
you can do with
your own dead body.
Anthony here for D News,
and why just get buried.
That is boring.
And also as the population grows
and land becomes more valuable,
getting buried in a cemetery
is just sort of wasteful.
There just isn't space for them.
About 76 million Americans
will hit life expectancy
in the next 10
years, and it's going
to take a space the size of
Las Vegas to bury them all.
There is not room for
this kind of stuff.
Even in countries like England,
where 70% of the population
is cremated, things
are getting tight.
Plus, the human body
is full of all kinds
of amazing useful things,
so as a public service,
here are the coolest things
you can do with your body
instead of burying it.
You've got a lot
of carbon in you.
All living things do.
You just so happen to be
about 18% to 24% carbon.
So why not get yourself
turned into a diamond?
A company like LifeGem
will use chemicals
to extract the carbon from your
ashes, turn it into graphite,
and then throw it into a chamber
that mimics the intense heat
and pressure at the
center of the Earth.
And in a couple weeks, boom!
You're a precious gem.
I mean, as far as I'm
concerned, you already were.
But now you are literally.
So what now?
Well, you could be
the ghost inside
of a haunted ring,
which is cool.
Or you could potentially be
part of an nanoscopic MRI
or a quantum computer.
UC Santa Barbara
researchers think
that sheets of synthetic
diamonds patterned
with nitrogen atoms could make
computers about a million times
more efficient than silicon.
And the atomic
impurities of them
might make them the
perfect candidate
to be the building block of tiny
magnetic field detectors which
could be injected
into the human body
to allow us more precise
medical scans than ever.
So just get yourself turned
into a pile of diamonds,
and send yourself to
the nearest college.
Does that sound too
pedestrian, too useful?
How about just shooting
your ashes into space?
For $2,000, Elysium Space will
launch a vial of your cremated
remains off into
the final frontier.
The company was founded
by an ex-NASA employee,
and the cost
includes a mobile app
that will let your
loved ones track
your endless voyage
to the stars.
But if you want to
stay closer to home,
rival company
Celestis will put you
on a satellite orbiting
the earth for $5,000.
Now some of you might
be saying, wait,
if we are trying to save
the Earth's resources,
why are we buying into something
that takes as much energy
as a spacecraft launch?
To which I say,
"Spaaaace!" [FADES AWAY]
But if you're looking to be
carbon neutral even in death,
maybe you want to die in Sweden,
specifically Halmstad, Sweden.
When locals wondered
about the pollution
from the town's
crematorium, city officials
came up with a plan.
Using the furnace
from the crematorium
to power homes in the town.
Just a tiny, adorable, little
power plant run on dead people.
One last way for your
Nissan LEAF-driving friends
to show their superiority
to you before they
go into the great beyond.
By the way, my idea of being
stuffed, that is not legal.
But you can be mummified,
though a sarcophagus
is going to take up much
more space than a coffin.
The lovely people of
Summum will do it for you
for the sum of $67,000.
You know, you would think
for that much money,
they can afford
a better website.
I am still undecided, other
than being an organ donor.
What do you want to do with
your body when you die?
Let me know down below.
You can also check out a link
to an article from the Discovery
News blog with even more
ideas for dead bodies.